there are trillions of bacteria that
lives on and in that based on every
surface of our body like our skin or gut
everywhere and they basically ate us on
all these processes that our body is
incapable of doing on its own and so to
better at like all like figure out how
to engineer our microbiome we want to
figure out like what are these driving
forces behind the colonization of these
various surfaces so basically a lot of
the current research provides like
snapshots of our colonies our microbiome
and we just like know what is there but
we don't know how it gets there or like
why it gets there or like what how it
changes over time so you want to take a
look at these driving forces and we're
focusing on the skin because it's very
easily accessible I mean it's right
there so it's very easy to sample and
we've got very fine skills spatial
resolution to like figure out what these
forces are so what I'm doing right now
is optimizing a sample processing
pathway so this is very necessary visa
and then figure out like what is their
first of all and like figure out what
are the components with each of these
colonies and so this whole pathway is
being optimized at the moment but
basically it will end the DNA sequencing
so we can identify which of these traits
are present and then once we do that we
have all this data to play with and that
would be a lot of fun that we can like
figure out what is actually there and
figure out what the forces are so for
future like over IP / January like I
plan to start the actual sampling
process with like actual human subjects
and real-life pores and will be really
cool and so basically like once we start
that fine scale sampling process we can
figure out like what is growing there
how they're interacting with each other
how it changes over like the distance
that we sample at and using that we can
figure out what forces are applied